[Música]
Fue en un ambiente de profunda devoción
que el Papa Francisco presidió en este
día la misa del domingo de Ramos un
domingo que culmina una semana en la
cual el pontífice estuvo hospitalizado a
causa de una bronquitis Soy Francisco
apareció a bordo de su papá móvil se
veía en buen estado de salud saludo a
los fieles pronunció en la tradicional
bendición de Las Palmas luego permaneció
sentado mientras que un cardenal dirigía
a la ceremonia en el altar ya que
Francisco ya no puede estar de pie
durante mucho tiempo debido a sus
problemas en las rodillas durante su
homilía el pontífice evocó Los
sufrimientos del cuerpo y del alma que
Jesús soportó y los comparó a Los
sufrimientos hoy en día de las personas
más vulnerables los migrantes los
excluidos los pobres que viven en la
calle los pueblos enteros explotados
Francisco les envió un mensaje de
esperanza y exhortó a los fieles
católicos a romper La indiferencia hacia
las personas más débiles cerca de 30.000
personas asistieron a esta misa aquí en
la plaza de San Pedro en el Vaticano
[Música]